ARE NO PREPARATIONS UNDER WAY
FOR A SUMMIT.
>> Bret: RICH, THANKS.
THIS IS A FOX NEWS ALERT.
THE ASSOCIATED PRESS IS
REPORTING THAT NORTH KOREA
LEADER KIM JONG-UN SAYS HE WILL
SUSPEND NUCLEAR AND LONG RANGE
MISSILES TESTS AND SHUTDOWN A
NUCLEAR TEST SIGHT AND HIS
COUNTRY WILL SUSPEND TESTS FROM
APRIL 21st.
NORTH KOREA WILL STOP THESE
TESTS.
THE NORTH WILL SHUTDOWN A
NUCLEAR TEST SIGHT ON THE NORTH
SIDE TO PROVE THE VOW TO SUSPEND
NUCLEAR TESTS.
THE DECISION WAS MADE AT A
MEETING OF THE CENTRAL COMMITTEE
OF THE WORKER'S PARTY TODAY.
THIS IS ACCORDING TO KOREAN NEWS
AGENCIES.
IF THIS IS TRUE IT'S A MAJOR WIN
FOR THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION
PUSHING FOR THE DENUCLEARIZATION
AND SETS UP A POTENTIAL MEETING